welcome everyone to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant and on my channel i talk
about how to become successful in the
first years of your career and today
let's look into what steve jobs had to
say about consulting so of course if
steve says something we all better
listen steve surely is a great and
intelligent man and i found i think one
of the less known videos of steve jobs
where he commented on his perspective of
consulting the videos from a speech he
gave at mit where he essentially shared
two points on consulting so let's look
at them i think part of what he says is
correct but i do also think that this
view is at least partially flawed so
let's get into it how many of you are
from manufacturing companies oh
excellent where where are the rest you
from
how many from consulting
oh that's bad
you should do something
no seriously i i don't think there's
anything inherently evil in consulting i
think that
i think that without
without owning something
over an extended period of time like a
few years
where one has a chance to take
responsibility for one's recommendations
where one has to see one's
recommendations through all action
stages and accumulate scar tissue for
the mistakes and pick oneself up off the
ground and dust oneself off
one learns a fraction
of what one can what you're
coming in and making recommendations and
not
owning
the results not owning the
implementation
um
i think is
is uh
a fraction of the of the value and a
fraction of the opportunity to learn and
get better
so here steve jobs is essentially saying
that consultants do not own the products
of their work and do not follow through
with it in the execution but i think
it's fair to say that consultants of
course own the concepts and strategies
that they might develop especially maybe
consulting so mckinsey bc bane surely
it's correct that at least in most cases
you do not witness the execution of
these concepts and surely also not
responsible for them so the one side of
the story is that he is correct and i
did also witness sometimes even up to a
point where i thought that this was a
little bit arrogant that there was often
a little bit of the notion that actually
developing the concepts and the
strategies this is what the challenging
part is and then the execution that
wouldn't be that tough that difficult
and this is also the context in which i
released a video a couple of weeks ago
about the boston consulting group and
gamestop legal dispute where boston
consulting group was suing gamestop for
about 30 million dollar in consulting
fees if you haven't seen that i will
link it somewhere above here but this
video this whole topic was also very
much linked to the fact the boston
consulting group actually was not
responsible at least from their
perspective for the actual
implementation of the measures that
they're recommended and there seem to be
lots of disputes surrounding that so
this criticism the consultants do not
really own their ideas from end to end
from the very start where you
conceptualize them until they are
financially effective this is of course
a common criticism though here i often
wonder whether that's really a fair
point to make because let's look at
other roles in corporate let's look at
salespeople do they own everything of
the value chain of what happens in their
company no they are just sales people
they're selling products and you could
argue this is also only very limited
part of what happens in a company what
about accountants financial accountants
managerial accountants people working in
a controlling team do they really own
the company processes from end to end
well i'd argue they're very efficient
and capable in a certain area what if
you are a software engineer so you
certainly build something and are
responsible for the final product of
your work but here also are you really
owning it end to end here someone else
will usually conceptualize and define
the things that then you are supposed to
build so we get very detailed
descriptions usually from the product
team telling you what to do and then you
do just that is this really end-to-end
ownership now you could continue talking
about engineers working in rd or people
working in production i'd say that in
almost every role in a corporate
environment you are only responsible for
a certain part of the whole but not
everything and in this same way the
strategy consigns are responsible for
developing the strategy concepts and of
course many other things depending on
the types of projects they're working on
and which is not that different from
many of these other roads this way and
so
what what you you do get a broad cut at
companies but it's very thin
it's like a picture of uh i would i
could use i'm a vegetarian so won't you
steak it's like a picture of a
of a banana
it you might get a very accurate picture
but it's only two-dimensional
and without the experience of actually
doing it
you never get three-dimensional so you
might have a lot of pictures on your
walls you can show it off to your
friends you can say look i've worked in
bananas i've worked in peaches i've
worked in grapes but you never really
taste it
and and i think that that um that's
that's the right thing
so this point builds on the notion that
consultants don't really understand what
they're talking about that at best they
have a very superficial knowledge of the
things that they express their opinions
on and here again in favor of steve jobs
of course as a consultant you will
rarely have the knowledge that someone
has who's really working in an
operational way on a certain topic for
years and years and years of course such
a person will likely be more
knowledgeabilities on some parts of the
things than you as a consultant in
addition to that i do think it's true
also from my personal experience that
sometimes there's the problem that is
consultant you need to be perceived as
competent and you need to do things to
some extent fake this competency even
though you're still learning you're
still in the process of acquiring all
the knowledge that you need to acquire
there was a harvard business review
article a couple of years ago that
called this the learning credibility
tension that's a tension that many
people and professional services face so
it's not only specific to consultant but
a very relevant interesting topic indeed
i created a video about that a couple of
months ago i will also link it above
here with some very interesting insights
on that check it out if this topic
interests you but that being said i
still think that this notion that
consultants don't really know what
they're talking about in the end is
still very much flawed this way from my
perspective it's actually one of the
biggest advantages of having worked
several years in consulting that after
this time you will be able to have a
meaningful conversation with any senior
leader of most companies independent
from the industry or from the function
that the leader is working in just based
on your insights and based on your
contextual understanding of what the key
topics are that matter to these type of
people and of course also what they mean
on an execution operational level
because in the end of the day these are
things that you will at least have some
exposure on in your work as a consult in
this way on top of that the big variety
of different topics you will work on at
least in mbb consulting really enables
you to if then you need to go deep in a
certain part of your career also after
consulting to give you the confidence
that you can understand also complex
things in a short amount of time and
give you the ability to really amass
lots of knowledge in short time to get
this done and to make yourself
knowledgeable whenever this is than
needed so in the end of the day to me
this comes back to the old debate
whether being a generalist is better or
whether being a specialist is better in
my humble opinion there are very good
arguments to be made that especially in
the beginning of your career it makes a
lot of sense to become a generalist
first you will still have plenty of
opportunities later down in your career
to amass niche knowledge to mass
knowledge in a very specific domain to
become this very t-shaped profile
whereas on the one hand side a very
broad general understanding of things
and that also is able to go deep and has
the main expertise in some specific
areas that often makes a lot of sense
because if you specialize yourself too
early on in your career but i understand
that the rewards for that can be
significant as well then often it is
difficult then after years and years and
years in this specific role you then
want to do things which are very very
different from that but now i'm very
interested to hear your opinion as well
do you actually agree with what steve
jobs said or not just leave a comment
below in the comment section very happy
to have a conversation with you and as
always if you took any value from this
video at all destroy the like button for
the youtube algorithm and also subscribe
to stay up to date my name is heinrich
big big thanks to all the members of
your channel for your support are these
videos every single saturday see you
again next week until then all the best
to you and bye bye